I fought every rune bear in Elden ring
so that you don't have to.
There were 21 in total.
It was awful,
but one of them was worth killing.
And two of them were actually very unique.
See, everyone who plays Elden Ring
fights these things once or twice
and then just ignores them
for the rest of their playthrough.
Rightfully so.
Most of them just look like the one
I'm fighting now.
Some of them have an absurd
amount of health.
Some are covered in snow,
some are asleep, some weight, an ambush.
But overall their movesets and behavior
are largely the same,
except for one found here
south of the deep XI for a well in colored
and one found here southeast of the inner
consecrated snow field.
These two have ragged unkempt fur,
which I think suggests
that they're more feral than the others.
And it shows because their moveset
has all of the usual B.S.
but it also includes a skyward dive attack
and an AOP roar.
Not only that, but their health
and defense is just through the roof,
especially this one in the snow field,
which is basically an end game field boss.
It also just happens to be the only bloody
run bear that's actually worth killing.
You can find it here
buried in the snow as a wandering noble.
It's actually mimicked here.
And if you somehow overcome it,
you'll receive a larval tier,
which you can use to respec
your character.
Number two, while in Caleb.
Did you ever notice these piles of weapons
that litter its battlefields?
These, I think, help to convey the sheer
scale of the battle
where millennia fought to retain.
And they're mostly found
in these sections of Caleb
here, where millennia experienced her
first scarlet bloom, and here near Red
Main Castle in the arena that I believe
Rodan fled to after succumbing to the rot.
We talked really in-depth about Caleb's
lore in this video,
and it's obvious in retrospect,
but a lot of you guys pointed out
that they're actually curved great swords
among this pile of weapons,
and they look almost identical
to Riordan's Starsky
edged Great Swords,
suggesting that some of his soldiers
actually wielded
similar swords to their Lord.
Even though we don't find any soldiers
wielding them in game.
Another curious thing about Riordan's
swords is the inscription
they bear,
which is fittingly the same symbol
that gravity spells have the swords
actually reference this, stating
that Broden earned considerable renown
as the star scourge in his youth,
and it is said that it was during
this time that he engraved
the gravity crest upon these blades.
But what's really cool is that
this gravity crest is likely inspired
by real world models of magnetic forces,
which mark North and South magnetic poles.
These curved lines are likely
the resulting field lines
that measure the strength
and direction of magnetic fields,
which results in a graph
that looks a lot like the gravity crest.
Considering gravity spells
do pertain to the push
and pull of cosmic forces,
I can see the connection though.
Diving any deeper into this topic
makes my brain hurt, so I'll stop here.
Rodan initially learned this gravity magic
so that he could ride his scrawny horse.
Despite his immense size.
Then he furthered his knowledge
in order to confront
the falling stars
and seal the fate in the night sky.
So naturally, Rodan displays
this incredible mastery over gravity magic
in our fight with him, even
managing to manifest as a giant meteor
and devastate anything in his path.
But the big thing when missing from Rodan
story is why he went this far.
Why did he have to conquer the stars?
And to be honest, I've always felt like
we're missing something from this topic.
Take, for example,
the sword gravestone in Celaya.
It states that Rodan alone
holds CLIA secure.
Then consider these stars good heirloom.
It states that Rodan confronted
the falling stars.
It almost sounds
as if the stars were a threat in some way.
Right.
As if Rodan was taking defensive measures
in conquering the stars
rather than taking the offensive
initiative.
And there's a piece of cut content
that might just
explain
why the story is presented this way.
So in one of his
all these videos, she presents evidence
that a still the malformed star
boss might have actually been
a part of your fight with Rodan.
This is because I still actually
has a cut animation that shows them
descending from the sky,
covering this enormous amount
of distance in the process
and crashing to the ground
with the same fiery VFX
that Rodan himself uses.
And while the fiery VFX is missing
from this descent,
Zoglin notes that the animation does
include fiery sound effects,
making the meteor comparison
even more valid.
So imagine you've just defeated
Riordan's first phase
and he disappears from the arena demigod,
defeated, Right.
The stars are free.
Suddenly a fiery meteor comes
rushing towards you, narrowly misses
and then unfolds to reveal Esto phase
two of Riordan's fight.
And the very thing that Riordan himself
was holding back from the world.
That's how I imagine it playing out.
At least it would have really driven home
the idea that Rodan
was preventing these falling star beasts
from making planet for.
And it's a really compelling theory
as to why Riordan
might have acted
as the star coach in the first place.
Now, obviously it's cut content
and it can't really be considered canon,
and I personally think that Riordan's
motivations can still be more complex
than just being limited
to this defensive action.
But perhaps this explains
why the law is so vague on this topic,
almost as if the obvious explanation
was removed from the game.
But speaking of Rodan and his wars,
so this character is the Knight Jarrin,
who served as a commander
in General Riordan's Wars.
And he has this very curious line
of dialog to say about e.g.
who was the blacksmith
for the Carrion royal family.
Bit of a haughty sort.
Strange fellow when I knew him.
And funny thing is
swords were all blood to stone,
but not one of them decayed
when faced with the scarlet rot.
We learn three fascinating things
from this dialog.
First, the e.g.
Carrion Royal Blacksmith actually
made weapons for some of Riordan's forces
who eventually came into contact
with the scarlet rot.
Second, we learned that
not one of these weapons decayed.
That's quite the achievement, as scarlet
rot is an incredibly corrosive force.
Even Melania's Knights
needed to have their weapons
consecrated in order to ward it off.
The only downside of these weapons is that
apparently they were blunt as stone.
Seems odd that they'd be used at all.
But I guess we just have
to take that quote at face value.
What's very interesting
here, though, is that next to e.g.,
we can actually see a greatsword,
which is a weapon that you can actually
loot for yourself in.
Caleb suggesting
that it might have been one of his weapons
that made it all the way there.
Not only that, but the Great Sword
is actually a recurring reference
placed in many of Fromsoftware games,
and it's this homage
to the Great Sword
that's wielded by guts from Berserk.
A weapon that is, and I quote, massive,
thick, heavy and far too rough.
It was much too big to be called a sword.
Indeed, it was like a heap of raw iron.
So I wonder, are these great swords
what Jaron is referring to
when he talks about his blunt weapons?
Maybe so.
Speaking of Berserk, a long time ago,
I commissioned this
displayed artwork from Francois Couto,
and it's a blend of BoSox band of the Hawk
and Bloodborne characters as well.
But even if this isn't for you,
I have a whole store filled with designs
that are just like this one.
Except they're inspired by Elden Ring,
Dark Souls, Bloodborne,
secular, everything.
Not to mention
you can actually get official Elden Ring
and Dark Souls
designs over on display now as well.
And for a very limited time
they're all 24% off 34% off.
Actually,
if you buy more than two displays
can bring a ton of character to your room.
They're easy to hang.
They have these nonstick pads and wall
magnets that won't damage your walls.
So if you're interested,
please click the link in the description
and consider
buying more than two prints for 34% off.
Special thanks to displayed
for sponsoring this video.
But let's get back to it.
For number six,
the Leonia maps all read as follows.
The majority of Leonia, known
for its vast forests
and ever
present fog, is sinking into a lake.
But why is it sinking into the lake?
The map says that it was known
for its vast forests and ever present fog,
but it doesn't say that it was known
for its marshes or swampland.
So surely it wasn't always like this.
What's more, did the order of real lucario
with all of their collective intellect
really think to build their academy
and surrounding town on a swamp?
Is it possible
they were that shortsighted?
I don't think so.
And as for why the land is sinking,
I feel like there might be two options.
Either this environmental change
could have been sudden
and caused by the shattering with water
maybe
spewing down from the north,
from the Altus plateau.
Or maybe the place was always watery.
But perhaps something else
has caused the land to soften from below.
So take a look at your map
and you'll notice
that the lake of rot
is actually directly below Leonia.
What's more,
if you look up from the lake of rot,
you can actually see a giant limestone
crystal peeking through the roof,
which I think confirms
that Fromsoftware did in fact
consider the upper and lower
alignment of these two places.
The Academy relies upon this glint stone
that they built
their entire academy on top of
so in order to claim it,
maybe they simply looked past lands,
poor foundations or something like that.
But anyway, the lake of rot is seething.
It's constantly steaming
and filling the air with its pollution.
So I feel like it's a fair theory
to think that this could have slowly
eroded the land above over time, causing
Leonia to maybe sink into the lake.
Special thanks to Kellogg
linked in the description
for bringing this up to me ages ago.
But what do you think?
Speaking of environmental analysis,
two months ago, someone on Reddit
discovered these reliefs etched on
two pillars at Nicholas Haley's tree.
They then attempted to extrapolate
meaning from them.
Fair enough.
The floral design at the lower end,
they claimed, depicted Melania's
first second and third blooms
from which the root goddess emerged.
Continuing up, we see an enclosed owl
supposedly representing sublime slumber
enjoyed by Mikala,
who is in the womb, only to emerge
in this elder state, having quelled
the curse of eternal childhood.
So this post received over 2000 updates,
and a lot of people
clearly took a liking to the theory
until someone pointed out
that these pillars
are also found in path of Exile
a different game,
meaning that path of Exile and Elden Ring
clearly exist within the same universe.
Or that Fromsoftware
bought this asset from a public asset
library in order to save time and money.
You know, it's
probably that second one, actually.
I like that someone in the comments claims
that this situation came about
because of Epifanio,
which was a good word to learn,
because it is a word
that refers to the tendency to perceive
a connection or meaningful pattern
between unrelated or random things.
And it's so easy to be guilty of this
when analyzing from software's lore,
you'll come up with a theory,
and before long you're looking for
any evidence that proves your theory
and strokes your ego
rather than looking at all of the evidence
objectively as you should.
It reminds me of this video
I made a while back where I argued that
all of the Souls board games
were canonically connected to each other
as in all their stories bled into one
another and told one big story.
And in that video I was really clear
that that video was just for fun
and I was very clear
that I was purposefully cherry
picking arguments
in order to support my theories.
And yet still a lot of people
in the comments bought into the idea
and started to actually believe
that the games were connected.
So that video now serves
as a very good example.
A warning that it is very easy
to be misled by someone
if they're speaking with confidence
on a topic
that you are not completely familiar with.
Anyway, back to the reliefs.
I'm not saying that all architectural
analysis of Elden Ring is invalid.
It's not a lot of Elden rings.
Architecture is probably handcrafted
with intent and you could even argue
that the public assets
that Fromsoftware do use were chosen
because they align perfectly
with Elden Ring's lore.
But I do think it's naive to think
that every single thing
in Fromsoftware
games are handcrafted with intent.
And I do think it's important to remember
how easy it is to be misled.
Speaking of which, this next secret also
deserves a healthy dose of skepticism.
So as they were fighting Godric.
User Jack Newby 555 noticed
that while Godric is right
leg is a mass of flesh,
his left leg is armored,
and it's this left leg that Godric uses
to summon storm winds for his attacks.
Most importantly, they argue that this leg
looks suspiciously similar to Commander
Nyle, someone who summon storms
with a stamp of their foot as well.
So how likely is it
really that Godric took Nigel's leg
and bolted it onto his own body?
Well, unlike the previous secret,
I actually think
this one has a lot of merit.
Let me explain.
So, Commander
Nigel is a veteran general of Seoul,
a lone survivor who commanded spirits
to defend his long past master.
But apart from that description,
we actually know very little about him
and his allegiances.
And the same goes for Commander O'Neill,
who is another veteran
boss of similar design.
But what's relevant to us here is Niall's
prosthetic leg and its description,
which reads Bladed prosthetic leg
and wreathed with the power of lightning.
Commander Nigel, veteran of Castle
Seoul, offered this prosthesis
in exchange for the lives of defeated
knights held prisoner.
As I was reading this,
something immediately stuck out to me.
Why does it say that
Nigel offered this prosthesis?
That doesn't make sense.
How could he have offered up a prosthetic
leg that he actually uses in his fight?
So I went to our trusty translator, Loki,
who reveals that the Japanese text
actually just says that leg,
meaning the true description,
is probably more like Commander
Nigel offered his leg in exchange
for the lives of defeated knights
held prisoner Godric and Godfrey.
Two, for that matter,
are the only major players in the Elden
ring that I can think of
who would actually be happy
to receive the offering of a leg
as payment for something.
And Niall
and O'Neil are both missing legs,
which could explain both Godric
and goto Freud's possession of them.
So I think it's a great theory
that could easily have been a situation
where Godric or Godfrey held Niles Knights
prisoner,
leading to the offering of a powerful limb
in exchange for their safe return.
The best counter evidence to this theory,
though, is that Godric and Godfrey
are actually using right legs
as left legs here.
But as pointed out by some others
in the comments,
this probably wasn't a deal breaker
for Godfrey or Godfrey.
And at the very least,
if you don't like this theory,
I think that this could easily
be the leg of any banished knight as well,
who were a class of warriors
who mastered storms
and who could have passed that mastery
over to the grafted.
Of all the characters in Elden Ring,
Roderick is the one who was the most
personally affected by the grafting,
for she ventured to the lands
between from across the sea,
only to barely escape with her own life.
Everyone's been grafted.
Everyone who came with me,
they crossed the sea for me.
They fought for me
only to have their arms taken,
their legs taken, even their heads taken,
Taken and stuck to the spider.
According to her crimson hood,
Roderick is expatriated
royalty from another land
and received this cloak as a gift,
which made it somewhat easier
for her to be sent on her way.
She can be seen wearing it
in your first few encounters with her,
but she soon takes it off.
Why is that?
Well, a great law creator, Ms..
Charles, proposes that this moment marks
the point where Roderick puts aside
her past and starts
to carve a different path for herself.
She puts aside
the Red Hood that marked her as royalty
to be protected
and takes her future into her own hands,
becoming a spirit tuna at the round table
hold instead.
I love this theory.
For more insights like this,
be sure to check out
Charles's content on YouTube or TikTok.
I've been meaning to shout her out
for a while.
Another creator I want to shout out again
is Leviathan, who points out
that Arena is actually capable
of casting rejection.
I had no idea.
Leviathan argues
that this is the single weakest attack
in the entirety of Elden Ring,
and you should check out
his video on the topic because this is
actually a part of a longer video
where he finds out if this weakest attack
is capable of one shotting.
You go to his video in the description
to discover if that is indeed possible.
Number 11 comes to us from use
a typical painter 7052
who discovered that it's actually possible
to use America's mischief
in order to fool the eye of madness
in Leonia and evade detection.
I mean,
it might take you a while to get past it,
but good to know.
I guess these videos have always been
just a great way for me to tell you
about all of the disparate things
in the world of Elden
Ring that I couldn't
otherwise fit into other videos.
And only recently I realized that there's
actually a character in the game
that might just hate this idea
of teaching and learning.
And that's Elena of the Brier.
We've talked a lot about Elena before
and already uncovered a lot of his lore.
He hails from the land of Akkad,
which is a land of proudly
solitary ascetics,
and he was sentenced to death
for the crime of murdering
numerous instructors and merchants.
But what always bothered me about
his story is why
he wanted to kill these instructors
and merchants.
Why does he make such a spectacle
of collecting their bell bearings
and depriving you of their items
and their teachings?
Well, finally,
I think I might have an answer.
So the Brier great shield makes it clear
that Elena originates from Ithaca.
Right.
Which, again, is a land of proudly
solitary ascetics.
To be ascetic is to deprive oneself
of all forms of indulgence.
It's synonymous
with living a solitary life.
So what if Elena looks down upon
merchants and instructors,
people who share items and knowledge
because he thinks the world
would be better off without them?
He is a proud esthetic after all.
So maybe he's projecting that asceticism
upon the world by depriving everyone else
of their items and their teachings,
which he looks down upon
forcing everyone to rely on themselves
and nothing else.
I would never call this theory
absolute fact, but I think it might
just be the best explanation we have
in the absence of any other number. 13.
In Roundtable Hold, there are paintings
of many important characters
like Ratigan, which can be found here.
But did you notice that he's
actually posing in this painting?
Down here are his hands.
And while they look a bit off, because
you literally can't see any of his arm,
I guess it's to show that his arms
are absolutely straight out to the sides.
And this is important to his character
because Ratigan
was a very prominent
Golden order fundamentalist.
And this portrait makes it clear
that no one does the fundamentalist pose
better than him.
The gesture for golden order
totality can be done manually.
If you discover it
during gold masks questline.
And it will also be performed whenever
you cast incantations of the golden order.
Fundamentalists, many of which help you
to kill those associated with death
like the death birds,
which is really just an excuse for me
to segway into my next secret,
which revolves around the mausoleum
Knights soldiers
with wing shaped ornaments on their backs
to evoke the death boats,
a so-called self-inflicted curse that ties
the spirits of these loyal knights
to the land,
having willingly beheaded themselves
so that they may
serve their masters in death.
But did you know that this piece of armor
actually has a bloodstain
running down its back?
This is an amazing detail that references
the fact that these knights
were beheaded.
Credit to use a shadow bricks
who pointed this out a long time ago
for the final secret.
Let's return to Caleb and Melania, partly
because I need an excuse to shout out
this incredible piece of character
art created by Maureen Gray Roth.
This was inspired by a section
in my recent lore video on Melania,
where I speculated
that she might have a rebirth
to come
even after the player defeats her in game.
And since the of God has
a supposed connection to a great scorpion.
Maureen speculates
that this could be the result.
But what I really want to point out here
was that in that lore video,
you guys actually noticed
a piece of Melania dialog that I missed.
Is this my first
defeat?
Bravely fought so
that remember
one day
The Scarlet bloom will flower again.
This reads similarly to Ricard's line,
where he proclaims
after the fight that a serpent never dies.
So while of course we can't be certain
about how this cut dialog
was originally planned to be used, it
does seem to be another piece of evidence
that indicates Melania might rise again.
But other than recommending that
Caleb Love video again, I think that's
all they have to say for now.
Be sure to check out all the links
in the description because they will point
you towards talented creators.
And subscribing to all of them
will just fill your feed
with more from soft content,
which is always a good thing.
But thank you all for watching
and I'll see you in the next one.